national retail federation store
magazine came out with a list of the top
10 retailers these are the top 10
retailers better growing right now we've
got a list so this interesting stuff
here so amazon.com number one
sherwin-williams to chick-fil-a family
dollar stores apple tractor supply
company Whole Foods AT&T Wireless signet
jewelers Starbuck leave it up for just
one second here so there's this is kind
of all over the place and that's what i
thought was interesting so you've got
something like whole foods at number
seven that's really high-end stuff and
extremely expensive and then if you look
at number four you've also got family
dollar stores them another number five
like I mean you got and and then a
number five you got the extremely
experienced a mean actual apple but just
we have a nice million and the people
are moving apples yeah what's missing
yeah I want you walmart is missing from
that target is so it's in terms of
growth that's why so this is going
better growing right now significant
okay that's why I thought this was
particularly interesting so you've got
companies that are extremely expensive
and things that are really cheap and
doesn't that pretty much sum up
everything in America because there's a
bacon disparity right it's the gilded
age again that else happening people
realize it I was at a party the other
night and I was trying to explain to a
guy that the middle class has been
decimated and he smirked that music
they've been decimated hey do you have
any kids you try to send him to college
is your house under water is did you
lose your retirement when the stock
market crashed uh did you know that
fifty percent of all wages in America
make less than thirty thousand dollars
do you know that sixty four percent of
Americans have [ __ ] zero savings for
retirement yes the middle class has been
decimated and that's that you know what
it I thought oh maybe I'm reading too
much into that that's why but you that's
exactly your point that if they're going
after high end people in low-end people
write it up it's burgers and yachts I
guess sherwin-williams there therefore I
mean I look I think that that's true I
don't know that that list represents
that first of all I didn't realize we
were in the paint age but you know I'm
like sure Williams exploding what do
they go that uh that uh I'll for crying
out loud
they do in the Benjamin Moore isn't my
kidding I forgot about that one hour
you're gonna sweat everybody all the
Hurricanes they sell a lot more stuff
aight that's what i think that's a thing
can we put the list up again as like
some of it is like you know a everyone
has become a while even for people right
nobody doesn't have a cell phone not
nobody but almost everybody thought like
tractor supply that suggests that the
guy don't know growth in farms Starbucks
is high-end coffee but like the Jew I
don't know chick-fil-a is cheap and and
the paint store might be cheap and every
an AT&T Wireless I suspect that that's
perhaps because the base of wireless
customers that's growing might well be
lower end people well that's what I
think that is what it is because they
have their subsidiaries like cricket
which work off the AT&T yea networks but
they're much much cheaper they throttle
your dad on all that what you guys make
a chick-fil-a I guess that whole
anti-gay thing didn't really hurt them
on no that seems to help it helps a lot
helps out a lot ride a chicken I as much
as I like you in general I don't like
gays anymore and uh I might like him
again in the in the future but today's
depending on how hungry I am and yes
true yet so we were driving to Rehoboth
Beach Delaware which is a Gehrig a
Bradley Fighting appointing a bucket on
record I'm sorry very friendly uh Joe
Biden's been their job I've been there
right it was there were two bottles of
his house so we drive up and out and
we're hungry and we pull into a uh uh uh
outlet mall and the only place that you
can eat in the outlet mall was a
portable chick-fil-a I mean check filet
wait what does that mean important i got
like a chick-fil-a truck oh geez and i
know that existed right well they exist
and so a chicken truck and we're hungry
and it's the middle of delaware uh which
is gonna take 10 or 15 minutes to get
the end of delaware uh and uh but we
were hungry and that's where were worth
my nine year old father uh and i hadn't
eaten chick-fil-a in two years a tough
moment so you ate it I a chick-fil-a and
did you realize as you reading it you
were you were kicking me in the night I
did I did and but the hang of it
I ate it and I really I felt terrible i
was like i went two years I go to
Atlanta every six weeks I don't eat it
you know the possible at the Atlanta but
I think there's an exception for a
mobile truck I think there's a definite
caveat I would rather eat it a [ __ ]
sandwich then going in the chick-fil-a
I'll tell you that that I can be
arranged to that's what I'm saying I've
had a few